my goal isn't to make it to the nba my
goal is to stay in the nba because most
people just try to get to the nba and
they think their job's done i know that
whenever if i'm fortunate enough to get
the nba
the job's just getting started because
it's your life now
[Applause]
if you obtain the
spot of number one
everyone's always looking at you people
are going to say oh he doesn't deserve
that oh he didn't work for that no one
really knows how much time and how much
dedication you really have towards the
game of basketball it's just something
that people really just don't respect
i know that everyone's always going to
be looking at me when i step on the
court they're going to either have to
double-team me or change their style of
play to stop me i'd definitely say that
there's a target on my back but that
doesn't change anything that just means
i need to work harder so that no one
could beat me i know that i'm going to
go up against some pretty good people
out there really a lot of good players
that doesn't mean anything because i
know if i get in the nba they're all
going to be good
playing at peak game with team final
playing along teammates like jaylen dern
imani bates corey floyd justice williams
ottego away and many other teammates
just playing on that team was just a
great experience because everybody on
that team knew their job we knew that we
all had a great talent everyone could
play basketball i'm grateful for that
because the amount of my game that has
changed since then
is
i just keep looking up to what jalen has
been doing and what he is doing monty
too because both of them
they took the step they took the step up
out of high school to get into college
so that's something that i've been
thinking about but i decided to stay at
west sound and just work on what i can
do
[Music]
time that i spent at west town playing
under john bullajack frank hepnag
watching them and just trying to learn
from them has helped me being able to
just be a role model because now we have
like younger players on the team we have
an eighth grader on the team who's seven
foot
so being able to just have them look up
to me is just another reason to keep
pushing
i feel like going to college is just the
right spot to develop mentally
physically and just have your game just
blossom into something different because
college and high school basketball
they're just two completely different
games the floor is bigger
the overall competition is better and
people are just trying to fight for the
best spot
whenever duke really started to recruit
me the start of it was with john schatz
he was the first person to pick up the
phone to call me to call my mom
and just from then on just building our
relationship is just something that i
really cherished because he cared about
me he cared about my future and he cared
about my mom most importantly i'm just
excited to first step foot as a freshman
there to start working just start trying
to get better playing alongside tariq
whitehead kyle flukowski jayden just all
of those players i know are trying to
get better
[Applause]